ladies and gentlemen and welcome to
binge battle on this episode word
talking lost remember the show that was
some people thought it was just another
survivor then they said oh no no way
this is something totally different and
interesting and strange and it was our
introduction to the wonderful mystery
box of JJ Abrams the show ran for six
seasons culminating in a very
controversial final season and final
episode which we're about to celebrate
the 10th anniversary of May 23rd 2010 uh
we were all so young it's been that
decade since we got to argue about lost
and now that we've had some time to
think time to reflect we're gonna get
into all of the goodness that is lost
and all the controversies that that
entails here on binge battle my name is
Mark Ellis I'm just gonna be the host
the referee for this madness our two
contestants today not only they to my
dear friends through to monster Lost
fans as their memorabilia and a lot of
the stuff that they wear day in and day
out will attest to introducing first is
your challenger today he is not only a
great human being you can catch him on a
number of different shows podcasts that
he'll tell you about he is also a staple
at every comic book convention that you
will go to so unfortunately we're
waiting for those to open back up but in
the meantime we haven't virtually and
that is the one the only valley folk
mister himself Steve Zaragoza how you
doing buddy what's up thanks for having
me this is very exciting
Steve we're very excited to have you how
is your your quarantine been how are you
staying sane my friend Animal Crossing
and marijuana it's legal here in
California folks oh you saved those
comments for another day speaking of
marijuana no speaking of being a parent
blog I am happy to introduce your
returning champion she boldly went up
against one of the best that I've ever
seen how running and defeated Hal
Rudnick when it came to Breaking Bad
that is a host of the rock star ladies
and gentlemen the one the only miss Roxy
stryer Roxy how we feelin today
I'm feeling really good right now and I
I do love that in our minds during
quarantine somehow lawn and Hal have
morphed into the same human they both on
Harris I understand it's been a quite
the quarantine and if you want to say I
defeated how then I defeated how also
I'll take that another notch on my belt
but myself I blamed the Dharma
Initiative for doing some sort of weird
tomfoolery with my head and what I'm
remembering versus what actually
happened in the same way that Ken Burns
would be accusing the last dance of
pledging some numbers and pledging some
cash but like we're not here to talk
about the last dance if you tuned in on
time then you maybe want a Fandango now
promo code courtesy of the last dance or
one of our other trivia question but
that is all preamble to big battles what
we do here on this shows we have four
round and it is gonna be Roxy not vs lon
it's actually gonna be Roxy versus speed
so maybe our four board keeper is
enjoying some of the grass that he's
Eric with with all that being said it's
four rounds and each round what the way
that everybody out there votes for who
they like better is simple Roxy Strider
if you like her argument you like what
she has to say about a particular round
or character or moment better then you
click the like button if you think Steve
has the more firm argument then you
click the heart you're voting with your
thumbs you're voting with your hearts
both competitors are gonna do a great
job I assure you of that but we can only
have one winner if we're tied at the end
of four rounds and we will go to a
sudden-death overtime round throughout
the duration of the match we want to
hear from you so comment chime in along
with us as though you were arguing
amongst yourselves let us know what you
think about each category and then once
I said it's time for the final answers
please chime in with your likes or with
your hearts and let us know if it's Roxy
or Steve in your eyes alright we're
about to get going each competitor is
gonna have about a minute to open their
argument I'll give you about a 30-second
rebuttal and then you're each gonna have
about a ten-second closer to drop the
mic on the argument and leave it to the
audience to decide so Steve Zaragoza are
you
ready yes sir I'm ready and Roxie stryer
the returning champion you pumped and
ready to go
born that way baby and then we're off
and running with your first round here
today and lost it's simple throughout
the six seasons who or what was the best
character the Challenger Steve Zaragoza
is gonna go first you got about a minute
at your ready sir uh without a doubt I
think Locke is the greatest character on
the television show Lost and the reason
why is because every single episode with
Locke in it where he was the focus
because you know they have like Jack
centric lock centric gate centric
whenever it was a long trek episode it
was the most compelling
it was the most sci-fi angled oh that
foot shot of them in the Gulf and in the
Earth's but it's just everything is
compelling about the lock so especially
since it's episode four where you learn
about Locke in a really big way and
that's like okay I'm on board Locke is
just incredible and look there's a lot
of great characters in the show but
Locke's arc is tragic and entertaining
and mysterious and and just really cool
I think I think he had the most
interesting background backstory of any
of the characters all right Steve well
you already have a lot of commenters
agreeing with you Zubair chimes in and
says Locke because he had an amazing
backstory like you pointed out and is
the most resourceful character and then
one of my favorite comments already roxy
is that nobody can pick who their
favorite character is because they fell
in love with so many of them and then
they killed us okay it's tough to pick
who you actually want to glom onto
because you don't know they're gonna be
around for the next season or even the
next episode
Roxy how do you counter Steve Zaragoza
with his lock listen with an ensemble
cast like this there's a lot of
incredible characters to choose from and
Steve could have picked any of them he
could have picked Charlie could have
picked Desmond could have picked Jack
could pick Sawyer all incredible
characters alrighty ladies in Jeff
welcome back to binge battle on a
different stream apparently what
happened is the smoke monster
remember the smoke monster from lost
where it would come in at random times
then it leaves and you're like what the
hell was I thought I was watching a show
about people surviving a plane crash I
thought this was like Tom Hanks in a
Wilson situation and then I see a smoke
monster that got into the wires in the
ethernet around the offices here at
Fandango and Rotten Tomatoes but luckily
we have rescued the stream and we are
now ready to continue our binge battle
momentarily if you're tuning in I want
to give you a little bit of time to
catch up to get over to the news stream
and to get commenting once again because
I got to tell you I've hosted a number
of these things now I posted a lot of
virtual things in my life the comments
on this particular one you all seemed
ready to talk about lost you all seem
like we haven't gotten the outlet to
vent or praise or just discuss
everything that went into the six
seasons of this show until now so on its
tenth anniversary almost here of the
season finale and the series finale on
May 23rd 2010 we want to give you all
that opportunity so along with both
Roxie and Steve my name is Mark and I
want to welcome you all to our new
stream where you can comment at your
heart's content but I also want to
remind you all that you are in control
of which one of our competitors wins
each round and ultimately who's gonna
win today's lost binge battle if you
think that Roxy stryer had the better
argument overall in a particular round
you just like her choice better then
click the like click that thumbs up if
you think Steve Zaragoza was the better
option in a particular round or users
have fallen in love with his quarantined
beard click the heart for Steve that's
how you're voting and then I'll tabulate
it in my algorithmic head and we'll
announce the winner of each round as we
get there now if you were watching on
the previous stream we had then you see
on the we just started round number one
when the smoke monster attack so Steve
Zaragoza a very nice opening salvo for
the new challenger defending Locke as
his favorite character the question was
best character Steve argued Locke and he
argued him very well
mentioned backstory that he had the
character art the growth in the journey
that character goes on and improved
flashbacks get his
much more of luck and then I turn it
over to our returning champion Roxy
stryer she was ready to go she was
shooting Barb's like she was the Legolas
of the two towers at Steve's argument
and then we're about to find out which
character rocks me stryer took slow Roxy
if you can just kind of reset mentally
and emotionally in your head can you now
physically give us your opening minute
for the best character in lost history
absolutely because those few minutes we
had for me to really think about this I
have remembered how frustrating Steve's
pick really is because of his character
choice being John Locke I will get to
that but first I want to build up the
person I am picking who is absolutely
the best character on the show lost
which is hard to do by the way because
it's such an incredible ensemble and
that is Kate Kate the best character
because she's unlike anybody we had ever
seen before yes there has been love
triangles on shows previously but that
wasn't the but was at the center of her
character it didn't define who she was
her love interest or anything of that
sort we saw an incredible backstory from
her where she ended up murdering her
father so that she could save and
protect her mother and herself because
he was so incredibly abusive and that is
why she had to go on the run we when we
meet her we know eventually that she had
been the one in handcuffs that she had
been cuffed together and you're trying
to piece together why what did she do
because she seems to have such a genuine
soul she's the one who first sews up
Jack she's the one who sees in Sawyer
that he could be good and she was never
judgey of anybody she never thought she
was better than she listened to
everybody and decided to go on the
journeys to help her friends and try to
get them off the island
she wasn't pretentious she wasn't
annoying she was all around a pretty
kick-butt female character which again
at that point was not something we were
seeing on TV often those arms dough that
was ripped City and yeah because of all
of that and more Kate was the character
that's why Evangeline Lilly has gone on
to have quite the unbelievable career
afterwards all right well Roxy stryer a
nice counterpunch to Steve Zaragoza
opening salvo there I
agree with Roxy and the yeah okay
definitely found the right tree to do
pull-ups on because oh yes indeed
grab the sixties but now we're gonna go
back to Steve Zaragoza before we do that
I do want to thank everybody for finding
the new stream we're getting so many
comments that are like welcome back that
are telling us that Callie Nichol says
yay glad you're back james Halleck
assures me says I'm here mark
don't worry so thanks to everybody
coming back in for a new ring and with
that now that we have eight and lock on
the playing field Steve we go back to
you for your rebuttal you got about 30
seconds have at it sir Kate's awful uh
Kate Kate it takes Kate so long before
she like is likable at all and it's
because of Aaron the baby that she the
Claire's baby that she has to watch and
she finally becomes a less selfish
person before that she's so selfish she
lies to everybody she's deceiving she's
she's two-timing she's basically using
Jack because I mean she's in love with
Sawyer the whole time let's be honest
about that but she's stringing Jack
along because she knows jack is the
leader and she could get the most out of
being like kind of leading Jack on and
you know I just think Kate is uh she's a
she's she ends up being a great
character I love Evangeline Lilly but
Kate is just like the worst for a very
long time right I know a lot of way
about Locke but just the fact that Terry
O'Quinn was able to pull off dual roles
on the series perfectly makes him stand
light-years above the rest
mark 30 seconds have at it
listen Kate is flawed absolutely what
makes great characters people who are
flawed she is conflicted who to go with
and we see that many times but
ultimately with Jack we know that is her
OTP and that's what's important let's
talk about Locke for a second who by the
way does not listen or care what anybody
thinks on the show he is the one who was
always right he's holier than thou
coming in on his high horse he's the one
who blows up the hatch and Hurley
screaming don't do it the numbers the
numbers he put the points a gun at
people multiple times in cool
jack threatens to kill everybody
actually does kill some people becomes
the leader of the others is not on our
team for most of the time is the most
judging arrogant person you don't talk
about this evening he lies the entire
show nobody knows what's going on with
him why do you have nice on the plane
why do you have these knives on the
plane he is the worst character even
when he is the man in black when Jesus
just murders all the people all the
people around black the worst so not
only are our two competitors saying that
they have the better choice they're also
saying that the opponent Joyce is the
worst character on this show Steve I
want to go back to you for your final
thought and before you give us your
final thought I'm gonna give me the
floor just for a little bit to kind of
recap your first argument that the folks
joining this news stream maybe didn't
get a chance to catch so as quick as you
can you know I mean I guess like there's
only one thing that I want to say about
Kate is I love that she like killed her
stepdad thinking that that was gonna
like make everything good and then it
like ruined her mom's life so she like
ruined her mom's life and also one last
thing about Locke um the first thing he
does when he discovers that he's able to
walk again after crashing on the island
is he's amazed for a moment because his
eating Wiggles tells him and get up but
then he starts to help people instantly
and Kate's just like I don't know she's
just like over off to the side kind of
doing her own thing
alright Roxy come get your girl Kate
decides to go on a massive hike to the
radio tower to get them off the island
she goes to the smoke monster through it
multiple times and is not afraid yes
Locke helps so does Boone is that a
point in his favor absolutely not he is
way more helpful and she is somebody
who's trying to get food trying to get
them safety not afraid of anything and
lot just goes off by himself he's a solo
dolo
loser loses lots to get to eat parts
first Steve get those last few votes in
the chat has a lot to say and before we
get to whether it's Kate or whether it's
Locke Frank
Morris chimes in and says mr. echo and
Desmond and Hurley are Frank's favorite
character so there's a lot of characters
to choose from and there's a lot of
different ways you can go with this very
open-ended best character question
Jennifer Jevons chimes in and says Kate
but then there's a questionable emoji
and I don't speak hiring so I'm not sure
if she's actually rooting for Kate or
she's actually weeping because somebody
said hey but I will tell you that Sean
Tuohy says that Locke is the best
character and so we're finally
tabulating the votes and I can say with
some confidence that Steve Zaragoza has
gone up early and he has cut the
champion here actually proxy stryer
Steve is up one to nothing so Steve
congratulations on your very first real
round win here in binge battle thank you
I just want to say I just want to thank
the Academy I want to thank God I want
to thank my family just you wait and
just you wait okay yeah well soon it
might be the same mistake that lon
Harris made last week where you get a
little too excited within one ground
so practically everybody wins versus
Steve Zaragoza in round number two and
round number two your most heartbreaking
death okay rocks you're gonna kick this
round off with about a minute which one
hit you the most this is the easiest
question I've ever been asked in my
entire life because this is not just the
most heartbreaking death of this show
this is the most heartbreaking death
that has ever been seen on TV and that
of course is the death of Charlie if you
even have reference to this show if
you've never seen an episode but you
know somebody who watched the show you
know not Penny's boat with the hand you
know that imagery because it was so
crushing to watch him go down to drown
while still being the good guy he was in
his soul and telling Desmond the
heartbreaking truth talk about a
heartbreaking moment Desmond is
heartbroken Charlie is heartbroken we
all do that Desmond said Charlie this is
exactly
you're going to die yet he does it
anyway he knows he's gonna go in there
and die and he does it freakin anyway
good vibrations
that's something that only a musician
could do we figured out why it has to be
Charlie and that was gut wrenching too
because everything he's loved his whole
life everything he's worked for that is
what ended ends up being his demise and
he became one of the fan favorites so
Charlie leaving the show him dying
through the looking-glass without a
doubt the most heartbreaking death okay
Roxy stryer showing y'all why she's the
returning champion Kevin Cardona
chimes in and says sorry Steve Charlie's
death and lost is whatever you say is
gonna lose because that death was just
that powerful but Steve it is your
minute so tell us what was your most
part Breaking moment Charlie's death was
very sad it's true it affected me an
emotional way and it sucked but the most
heartbreaking death was truly Jenin son
like without it because Charlie was like
Charlie did everything he needed to do
and he was very helpful in he was great
and I loved dynamic with Hurley and it's
a great character but Jin and Sun they
had such a complete of being the
argumentative couple that you know argue
about this in that and at first you're
like man Jin's a jerk I don't like this
guy then they completely change they
grow and then they're separated and then
son has a baby which Jin never gets to
meet by the way which is so
heartbreaking and then Jin goes back in
time and freakin son doesn't and then
son spends like the rest of the series
trying to get back to just - Jin and
then finally when she does
they literally die together and it's so
heartbreaking because of how hard she
tried to find her husband and they just
die in such a heartbreaking tragic way
in that submarine and truly it's just
you think about that baby that's never
gonna meet her dad that's just gonna
live without parents it's so
heartbreaking okay so Steve I'm gonna
stick with you for your 30-second
rebuttal before I go back to rocks you
strive so you're saying basically both
moments are really heartbreaking but
you're just weighing the child versus
the relationship as the clincher in your
argument I think it's the clincher
there's certainly some there's a lot of
things that lead to that but the
clincher is certainly that they've left
that baby that Jen will never mean okay
so Roxy stryer now it's on you I'm
seeing a counting nickels as a great
comment she says okay but Juliet - so
she can't decide between Charlie and
Juliet and so it seems like she might be
hitting the thumbs up to vote for Roxy
but if you think that Steve's right
click that heart Roxy 30-second rebuttal
is now yours let's be honest though and
this might say something about Who I am
Jen and son's death was actually kind of
beautiful because he does not have to
stay there he was able to leave and if
he had wanted to choose to leave to go
live his life be with the baby whatever
he needed to do but she was stuck and he
decided I'm going to stay here with you
because I'm not leaving you that was a
choice that he made to be with her and
at the end of the day the show was
ending and that was such a beautiful way
to wrap out their love and to wrap out
their characters on the show after
Charlie died we just kept living life
missing Charlie there was just no more
Charlie on the show and so the fact that
we didn't get him and he had this gut
wrenching death that was completely
selfless that had nothing to do with his
own love he he died because he was
trying to save people and unjam the
system that's the word heartbreaking it
wasn't beautiful it was gut-wrenching ly
heartbreaking yeah okay maybe it is
better to die at the end of something
that is the tie in the middle of
something Steve your last phrase to get
all the hearts you can voting for you
Charlie almost died like seven times on
the show before he actually died and as
a matter of fact that character was
prepared to die and actually wanted to
die quite a few times and so you were
set to for that character to die
essentially you were just waiting for it
to happen
with gin and son they had so much left
to do and by the time they died in the
series you were just like okay well no
one's safe
cuz Charlie they hinted at his death a
lot Jin and son were like these they've
got plot armor they're gonna be fine
it just it just made the show so
shocking at that point cuz it was like
okay all bets are off anybody can die
and I'm I'm in it's it's an argument
that is echoed by comments or Daniel
what water Escalante says we knew
Charlie was dying since Desmond
mentioned it so it wasn't as surprising
so Roxy it may have been as surprising
but nois emotional for you last word in
the argument is yours listen Jen we
legitimately thought was dead because we
watched him explode so we already had
made our peace with that in an episode
where Sayid Bernard and Jin we think
that they're all shot Hurley kills
people with a van Sawyer
ends up killing somebody Locke kills
Naomi the one thing that's talked about
is not Penny's boat that's the one thing
that's talked about from that episode in
which everything happened so it's got to
be Charlie's death alright well I think
some of our chat room is traumatized too
because I'm just looking at Darren
Hicks's comment he says I love you Steve
but I'm with Roxy on this one so it is a
very close race here to monitor and I
love deco bot has been chatting a lot
they go clearly a huge fan of loss and a
GoBot saying that people in real life
have Penny's boat tattooed somewhere on
their body and I think that that's a
pretty strong statement and with that
roxy stryer has gotten a little more
lights than Steve did hearts meaning
roxy has tied the score at one apiece
and we go to round number three here in
binge battle deadlocked at one to one
the comments are now flying off the
charts now that everybody is here in the
new chatroom
welcome late comers you're here and it's
tied and round three is the all-time
best episode so Roxy you have all the
momentum right now you are the returning
champion and the opening minute for the
all-time best episode goes to you which
one you got to pick so many incredible
episodes but of course because I'm
somebody who plays by all the rules a
lot of those episodes are two parters
you know the
hila is really two episodes through the
looking-glass as really two episodes so
I thought what is the best standalone
episode of the series and it has to be
the constant now this an episode of TV
that really plays out like a movie and
you could show this to somebody who
doesn't even watch the show and they
would say this is one of the top five
episodes of television of all time
Desmond who is a fan favorite which we
already learned from you guys chat when
we didn't pick him to argue for best
character he is very focused and
centered in this episode it's a
beautiful love story about him and penny
it's also a Christmas episode which it
gets a lot of Christmas lists because
people don't acknowledge that he says
he's not gonna call her for eight years
here she will not hear from him and she
just has to keep the same number she has
to keep the hope and then in 2004 on
December 24th he's gonna call her I mean
who listens to that but they're so in
love that she does and he does and Sayid
is an incredible friend here we learn
about this time-travel we get to see
more about Desmond's past life and learn
what happened with him and Penny which
we had so many questions about it's a
beautiful perfect episode of television
that is the best of lost and one of the
best of all time okay Steve we had time
travel love the holidays and most
incredible of all remembering someone's
phone number a remember when we all had
to do that care Steve there it goes you
get a minute to counter with your past
episode listen the constant is a
fantastic episode and if we could both
choose the constant I'm sure it would
have been a less entertaining battle but
and it's really hard to pick the best
episode in the whole show but I don't
want to go with what TV Guide thinks is
the greatest episode of the show because
the constant is a fantastic episode but
anytime you look up what the best
episode of lost is the constant is super
high up there and it's like yeah there's
something for everybody there's a great
romance story Desmond and Penny's
relationship is legendary I love the
show I won't argue that
but for me by the time we got to the
constant even though it is a [ __ ] I'm
sorry I shouldn't girth can I
I want to clean the f-word again listen
the point is is that it's a great
episode but for me man of science man of
faith it's maybe just the greatest
episode of a TV show ever it's the
second it's the first episode of the
second season it opens with Desmond in
the hatch
getting ready he's like making breakfast
and he's on an exercise bike and he's
like what is this what is this show what
has happened I mean we waited like 200
days for this episode what's in the
hatch we finally get to see what's in
the hatch and it's done perfectly the
mono cast song the the I mean
introduction of Desmond it's just it
just went full sci-fi - and that was the
that was the greatest thing about it it
went full it's when lost went full
sci-fi it before it was like this could
be ghosts this could be dinosaurs this
to be polar bears but now it's like okay
we're anything could happen on this
island there could be a hatch with a
shower and a food cabinet and and
washer/dryer and guns and a really cool
like mural it's just an undoubtedly
amazing episode of the show and the what
and my favorite absolute yeah I see a
lot of people that were initially saying
that there's no way that you can argue
against any episode that is not named
the constant but Steve starting to win
some hearts over rocks he's like so if
you think Steve had the better argument
so far click with your heart if you
think Roxy has the stronger episode
click with your thumbs Roxy I want to go
back to you because it seems like Steve
maybe has the best hook episode where
it's like what the hell is in this thing
and that was the episode honestly they
got me into loss but you're talking
about the episode that really resonated
with you the most emotionally so it's a
good back and forth another 30 seconds
for your rebuttal yeah listen man a
science man a faith great episode can't
say it's not but we've waited all this
time what's in the hatch what's in the
hatch and we're on a sci-fi show and
what's in the hatch is a person you know
that and that's fine and Desmond ends up
being one of the best characters but we
open the hatch and it's a person that's
not that's not insane
out of the realm of possibility you're
not explaining the smoke monster to me
there's not a polar bear down there it's
a human being and not only isn't a human
being but is a human being that we know
and so the threat is kind of taken away
here because Jack and Desmond have known
each other from off the island
they have that experience together when
they're running stadiums and Desmond
helped Jack's so we know Desmond's
actually a decent person so I don't feel
threatened by the situation when we're
down there so the stakes aren't quite as
high although it's a great episode it
just didn't elevate the show for me
okay Steve what about that episode man
of science man of faith which by the way
faith is an f-word
you can't say on this show we show to
you I have a dirty mouth listen like I
said it's very hard to choose the best
episode of this series I just had to
pick the one that resonated the most
emotionally with me Desmond and Penny's
relationship was fantastic the fact that
they got that phone call tugs at my
heartstrings it makes me sad it makes me
cry but truly that moment in the episode
is what makes that episode so good and
that's just one moment and it is a great
episode again I'm not arguing that but
on a man of science man of faith there
are so many things that happen it opens
up so many possibilities you know the
the movie you know the film the film the
Dharma Swan hatch movie the magnetism
the numbers you know it just it just
it's such a perfect episode there's so
many things that happen and in the
constant it's like the phone call is the
moment you remember and a man of science
man of faith there's just too many
things to zero in on all right the last
word pretty much we got from Steve
Zaragoza so Roxy gonna give you one last
ten-second phrasing to give us why the
constant should win it's not just the
phone call it's Daniel Faraday and
having to figure out about the mouse and
going back and learning more about all
of our characters and funny enough this
really is an episode about science and
faith because what's happening is
unexplainable but there is a scientific
aspect to it so it really embodies this
show and also standalone works for the
show and a stand
all right well David barber is our first
commenter I want to highlight says I
don't think that man of science man of
faith comes close to the constant and
then Lucy Fitzgerald counters saying
that she just simply thinks Steve Wynn's
Cody Campbell just wants everybody to
know that lost is the best show period
so Thank You Cody you have definitely
tuned in to the right live stream but we
can only have one winner you voted with
your hearts you voted with your heads
with your thumbs up for Roxy with your
hearts for Steve and the first horse out
of the gate doesn't always win the race
Roxy with a huge opening argument that
seemed to win over the entire Internet
but yet Steve came back methodically and
reminded us of the reason why so many
people myself like I mentioned included
got hooked into this show was what the
hell is in the hatch and what I would
consider an upset victory in this round
is actually Steve getting the win in
round 3 and so Steve goes up to 2-1
congratulation is we have to lean over
the returning champ
daggers so hard against the constants so
hard Roxy you got it now
oh I don't care about your hard times
right now Steve all right ladies and
gentlemen Steve Zaragoza trying to pull
the upset over our returning champion
Roxy stryer thanks to everybody who is
tuned in to our new live stream here on
binge battle the lost episode make sure
that you're following Rotten Tomatoes
here on Facebook click that like to get
involved in all the latest updates check
out binge central which is our hub for
all things streaming right now we move
on to what could be the final round in
today's show and the theme of that round
is drumroll please the ending the ending
of lost was it good or was it bad Steve
you got the lead the momentum is back
with you and you kick off round number 4
I don't think the ending of lost was
good or bad I think it was perfect and
for those people that to this day are
like will they were dead the whole time
you're so wrong and you make me so angry
because it's so easy to pay attention
and realize
that Jack's dad says everything you need
to know it is really strange and it is a
really unique finale to a TV show and I
know it wasn't what everybody was
expecting but I put so much faith in the
creators and the writers of the show to
do something with this incredible
once-in-a-lifetime television experience
I think the fact that everybody who went
through an incredible experience
together on that island getting to in
getting to meet again in the afterlife
because there it meant so much to them
to be together in this incredible time
in their lives and then to meet in the
afterlife is a beautiful idea I love
that idea that all my friends that I did
the coolest stuff with will be in this
like middle ground afterlife type place
before I get to go to whatever the next
place is I think it's beautiful I think
it's wonderful I think it's unique and
ballsy and different another show has
never gone there and I think it's
perfect okay so the options were good or
bad and Steve took it one or maybe two
not just higher than that Roxy he went
perfect how do you respond to the ending
of lost doesn't it sounds like Steve
liked it and you can't blame somebody
for liking something folks in the
history of athletic competition the
greatest games ever played are the ones
that exhausted both competitors to the
point where they could barely walk off
the playing surface whether it's a field
whether it's a court or whether it's a
virtual Facebook stream here in binge
battle that's what we've discovered here
today I said that the best art is told
in trilogies but now we have a bonus
fourth edition so maybe it's Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull but maybe it's like
Jurassic world and it just brings us
back to the place that we loved in the
first place that is the topic of today's
debate because lost is our show here on
bench metal and we're tied Rocsi striker
has two points so does Steve Zaragoza
our challenger which means only one
thing over time we are now about to
enter the overtime round of binge battle
and the way we do overtime is simple
it's determined by you the fans who now
jumped more stirring
you've crossed more streams than the
ghostbusters and doing so because now
that you're here you're gonna be voting
if you think Roxy has the better over
time argument click the like button
you're voting with that thumbs up if you
think Steve Zaragoza has the better ot
argument then click the heart that's the
love button you'll love see I know you
love both of them but you're gonna love
Steve are you know like Roxy and that's
how we determine a winner here today so
without further ado our overtime debate
topic that will determine the winner of
bench battle is what it's the most
shocking moment in the history of lost
Steve Zaragoza the brave Challenger
ready to step to the plate what is your
answer sir these were all very tough
these these questions and figuring out
what the most shocking moment in lost
was was kind of difficult but there was
one particular episode that came to mind
when I thought about the series as a
whole and what was most shocking to me
and it has to be walkabout which is
episode 4 of the entire series season 1
and walkabout is such an important
episode of the entire series because it
sets the tone for what would make this
the entire show so good which was just
the fact that they whatever you're
thinking might happen is not is never
what's going to happen and the fact that
Locke is seen as this badass with knives
and the reason why has knives is because
he was going on a walkabout which is a
normal thing I guess when you go to a
walkabout in Australia but he you know
he was just this guy that was like
feeding people on the island with boars
and he's just this mysterious guy and at
first you're like oh he's a knife guy
and it's probably gonna be creepy but
then you like see his backstory and it's
so tragic and it's so messed up how he's
just is kind of like bullied sad man and
then when you see him in a wheelchair
you're just like wait a minute
what and then you see the
crash flashback and he's wiggling his
toes and he just has that moment of like
what is happening why can I walk why do
my legs work and for me it was just like
okay this is my favorite show of all
time I've never seen a series do
anything like this and it's so shocking
to me that suddenly this island thereon
is what like a healing island or
something and that's so incredible
that's when the whole series was like
alright I'm in I'm locked in that's for
me right that's what shocked Steve so
Roxy Steve saying that the episode that
taught us that lock is a knife guy and
you were about to say that's not a knife
this is a knife I've started every
argument that way listen it's cuz you
should listen to this one listen here's
the deal if you go to a party and you
don't know the theme of the party you
can't be shocked by any theme that you
walk in if it's disco not shocking if
it's aliens not shocking cuz you didn't
know the theme in the first season of a
show you can't really be shocked by
anything cuz you don't know what the
show is up to you don't know what it's
capable of so they had already shown us
there's a polar bear so you're telling
me that somebody being in a wheelchair
prior to being on the island is shocking
we don't know enough about the show to
even know that that's shocking here's
what's freakin shocking here is when not
only did you go to a party and it's
disco but now it's 3:00 in the morning
and all of a sudden they pull the rug
out from under you and really you're at
a 90s theme party okay and that is of
course we have to go back we are in
season three we are at the finale
we have lived an entire life with this
show where we only done flashbacks and
all of a sudden you want to tell me in
the last few moments of this that we are
not flashing back anymore we're flashing
forward and now I have to grasp that not
only did we get off the island which I
didn't know we did but they want to go
back to the island what the flippin
freak is that bum dropped they said it
would be the moment that changed the
show forever and it did okay well I
don't know how Roxy's been
spending her nights but it appears that
before quarantine she was going to a lot
of discotheques it suddenly changed
theme at 3:00 in the morning knocking it
is indeed shocking as are both of these
moments so you all pick two winners
there's no doubt about that but only one
can be crowned the victorious arguments
so the last word for Steve Zaragoza is
what by the time we got to we have to go
back it is truly a shocking moment and
it was definitely a great moment in the
show but by the time we got to we have
to go back a lot of people had already
jumped ship from the show because it was
just so convoluted by that point and I
understand that I don't really agree
with that but I understand that and I
understand by that by the time we got to
Jack's Badbeard his fake beard we have
to go back moment it's shocking and cool
but again I really think wheel chair
moment sets the tone for that moment you
know and it's me it's more impactful
that they have to go back because of how
magical the island is and that's when
you really learn that the island has
yeah sure it has a monster a dinosaur
whatever it is that's making all those
sounds the polar bear it's like wooo
crazy it's a random island but when you
learn that it healed Locke then you're
like okay so this is like this is a
magical island and that's another very
happy moment for a show that magical
island Christine even so Roxy stryer
your final word in the argument that we
have to go back five words changed the
entire show and the people who had
fallen off came back after we have to go
back why does Jack want to go back and
why doesn't Kate there were so many
moments within that one moment and yours
is a whole episode reveal we're learning
about the walk about why he couldn't go
it's not a shocking moment because we
build to it this is a moment that
changed TV history
alright so many great comments coming in
from our viewers here on Facebook thank
you once again for bearing with us and
our technical difficulties and thanks to
our incredible tech team here at Rotten
Tomatoes for keeping us afloat and
really getting us to the island with
this crashed airplane but now that we're
here we can only have one winner you
voted with your thumbs up for Roxy star
you voted with your hearts for Steve and
I've seen a lot of shocking moments at
fans would say maybe some involving
Benjamin Linus or a smoke monster or yes
a hatch slash polar bear incident but
there can only be one shocking moment
and the most shocking moments of lost
declaring the winner of today's binge
battle is the first shocking moment that
we got on the show and that would be
episode 4 Plus Steve Zaragoza of binge
battle Steve you are the champion you
have upset Roxy stryer who was the
returning champion and now Steve you are
the champion of binge battle in a few
short words how do you feel ah shocked
shocked because Roxy's so right
but again by that time the show was
really had lost a lot of people you know
and it was just like it was shocking but
man that walkabout was the tone setter
yeah it looks like a lot of people
thinking that Roxy's moment may be the
most iconic of the entire show those
five words that she mentioned but it was
not the most shocking in terms of the
people watching here on Facebook so Roxy
Steve I want to thank both y'all for
such a compelling episode of binge
battle that took about as many twists
and turns and shocking moments as the
show that were the beginning itself
which would be lost so I do want to give
each you all a quick platform to let
everybody out there who is watching with
us know where they can virtually find
you and support you and all that you're
doing
during this quarantine and hopefully
after it's over Roxy you're up first
where can the kids check you out
vengeance will be mine and I will be
back to get my championship because this
is the most shocking moment you guys can
find me everywhere at Roxy Strayer and
on my own youtube channel youtube.com
slash Roxy stryer I love your
competitive spirit and it fell a little
short the Steve Zaragoza spirited the
bay
here today steve zaragoza where can all
the kids oh yeah there in the world you
can find me on youtube.com slash the
valley folk it's my comedy team that we
make sketches and fun things with and
also I have a podcast called dynamic
banter which you should check out we
talk about nerdy stuffs
I'm there too I can say Steve one of the
funniest guys that you will see on TV or
on the interwebs and I have absolutely
at the pleasure being invited on live at
the Roxy and it's a great show that Roxy
does each and every day to the hardest
working people in the industry and
that's coming from a guy who is just
looking up at both of them because I
take a lot of naps and play a lot of Wii
golf during my days I know quarantine so
thank you everybody for tuning in to
today's binge battle my name is Mark
Ellis my comedy special dog stepfather
is now available on Amazon Prime if you
want to go check that out I also want to
give a huge shout out to everybody over
Fandango now thank you so much for
supplying us with our prizes for
everybody that played trigging with us
remember that way back on the first
stream we had some people want some
delicious prizes from Fandango now
delicious in the form of content you can
watch this evening and I want to thank
everybody out there for watching not the
least of which was our tech team behind
the scenes getting us through this storm
we made it we're here ashore and I don't
think we have to go back to this but
maybe to the next binge battle where
Steve Zaragoza could be a returning
champion and maybe Roxy stryer wants to
duke it out with him about another show
we'll wait for all that to be settled in
the meantime for everybody here at
Rotten Tomatoes my name is Mark Ellis
and we'll see you soon
you